80% des immigrants s'en vont à Montréal
travaille pas parle pas français ou
nadhère pas aux valeurs de la société
québécoise le ministre Jean Boulay a
premièrement déclaré que 80% des
immigrants s'établissent à Montréal
c'est une affirmation qui mérite des
nuances
[Musique]
dit aussi que les immigrants qui
s'installe à Montréal ne travaillent pas
et ne parle pas français c'est faux dans
les deux cas
79% des immigrants qui demeurent dans le
Grand Montréal on y connaissances du
français par contre c'est plus élevé
dans le reste du Québec ça grimpe à 89%.
et le taux d'emploi des immigrants au
Québec est un peu plus élevé que celui
des gens qui sont nés au pays dans la
grande région de Montréal
65,2% des immigrants ont un emploi
contre
63,7% pour le reste de la population les
cas s'explique notamment parce que les
immigrants sont plus jeunes en moyenne
et donc plus susceptibles de travailler
en ce moment au Québec près d'un emploi
sur 5 est occupé par une immigrant leur
contribution au marché du travail et
donc supérieur à leur poids
démographique
[Musique]